[Music]
any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic don
this is a great pleasure i'm talking
today with professor don
hoffman who's an american cognitive
psychologist and a popular science
author
he is a professor up the road at the
university of california irvine
he has joined appointments in the
department of philosophy the department
of logic
and philosophy of science in the school
of computer science
he's written many books today we're
going to be talking about a very
provocative book
called the case against reality and you
can find some more information about him
on his ted talk this is really where i
got introduced to him
called do we see reality as it is you
can find that wherever ted talks
are sold don it's such a great pleasure
to uh
to meet you uh videographically and
elsewise uh
how are you doing today well thank you
so much brian it's a great pleasure i'm
doing very very well and it's a great
pleasure to
talk with you thanks for this kind
invitation ah the pleasure is
truly all mine and i followed you we
have many friends in common
we have many interests in common and the
first thing i love to do
because uh it's it's a nice way to kind
of open up the conversation
is by doing what we're always advised
never to do
which is to judge a book by its cover
and
i want to ask you how you came up with
this very delightful delicious
uh delirium inducing cover uh image
for the case against reality so if
you're at home folks go to amazon.com
buy a copy of the book i can't recommend
it highly enough i just gave it a five
star review it's got 534
five-star reviews and up anyway don
how'd you come up with the
cover image and the title and subtitle
because it's very provocative
are you talking about the the version of
the united states from norton
yes or the penguin right so that
that is actually the the brainchild of
um
a guy named uh haywood petri
and uh bradley dumais so this is a
well-known subjective necrocube that's
been around for
for since the 1976 1977
and so it was just adapted a little bit
um for for the cover so
so petry and bradley deserve all the all
the credit for that
um it's their brainchild and the title
um yeah it's a bit provocative uh
i do believe that there might be some
kind of reality but the point is that
what we take to be reality isn't the
reality and that's
that's what the book is is after whether
there's a real reality beyond what we
believe
is an interesting and open question but
at least the space-time reality
space-time and physical objects that's
where i think evolution
might say that we need to rethink things
and the subtitle is equally provocative
in my opinion
the subtitle for those who aren't uh
haven't yet
received the delivery in their amazon
real-time delivery system which i'm sure
will be coming
any day now uh is the the subtitle is
why evolution
hid the truth from our eyes now don
uh i'm not that great a scientist but i
was always told that
science that science can't answer why
questions um why why did you use the
word why
but i always thought science answers how
questions first of all where am i wrong
because i'm sure i am right so this has
to do with the logic of
evolution and evolutionary game theory
so
in evolutionary game theory we we can
actually
ask the question technically would
natural selection shape sensory systems
of organ
organisms like humans but but of any
creatures would would their sensory
systems be shaped
to tell them truths about objective
reality
whatever objective reality might be and
that's that's a question that we can ask
very precisely using evolutionary game
theory
and the reason i can say why is because
i can say
why the logic of evolution itself
entails the probability of zero
that our sensory systems are shaped to
see
any structure of objective reality so
whatever objective reality might be
whatever structures it might have
one can prove and this is work that's
been done in collaboration with some of
my graduate students and then a
mathematician so the graduate students
are
justin mark and brian marion and and the
mathematician
uh chaitan prakash and others that have
worked with us on on this
and what what the simulations
illustrated and what the mathematics
proves
is that the probability is precisely
zero that any structure of objective
reality
would be preserved
in the sensory systems of any organisms
by natural selection
so we're going to be selected to see
something or to perceive
something the question is the structure
of our perceptions will they
somehow capture true structures in
objective reality
and the answer is no almost surely and
so that's why evolution
shapes us not to see reality um because
the probability is zero
um that it could and and we can go into
why but the the real
the the the interesting reason to me is
that
you can think about evolution is like a
game
like a video game right and when you're
playing the game what you have to do is
grab points as quickly as you can if you
get enough points in a shortened
amount of time then you can go on to the
next level well in
in everyday life with natural selection
it's like a game
the the fitness payoffs are the the
thing that
sort of counts like the the points of
the game and if you get enough fitness
payoffs
um you don't go to the next level of the
game but your offspring your genes go to
the next
level of the game and and so so it turns
out that the payoffs when when you
look at the structure of these payoff
functions in evolution
the payoff functions that are again like
the rewards that you get in the video
game how many points you get for killing
that that alien or you know driving that
car that fast and so forth
all the points that you get those payoff
functions and evolutionary theory
do depend on the state of the world and
the structure of the world
but they also depend on the organism
like a human versus a
a cow versus a lion uh it's state hungry
versus stated
and the action feeding fighting fleeing
and mating
the the big um uh activities of life
and so it depends on all these things
including the structure and state of the
world
however when you what we did was a
combinatorial study
we can ask how many we can look at all
the possible payoff functions
we can count them and then we can ask
how many of those payoff functions would
actually preserve a particular structure
in the world say
a topology we didn't do topology but we
did measurable structures
certain kinds of groups and and also
total orders and what we find in each
case is that the probability is
precisely zero
uh a zero percent fraction of the total
payoff functions
would preserve the structure of the
world
so so the bottom line is the reason
why evolution by natural selection
does not shape us to see truth is
because
the payoff functions that guide
evolution
don't contain the truth almost surely
that's why
and when we think about truth uh of
course you know the common parliament's
truth is subjective there are
alternative facts there's fake news
um so there there is sort of a theme
running through the book of
you know reality kind of being created
as you say you know almost
virtual reality without the virtual in
other words we we sort of have this
headset that we're
uh encased in and it's the overlay of
perception
i want to start uh by going back to the
beginning of all this at least
in terms of both not only the scientific
method but
deep influence on me and on you i know
for sure and that's this
finger puppet for those of you on
clubhouse cannot see this is a finger
puppet of galileo galilei
that i whip out on occasion uh he's
called the father of modern science
he's certainly the father of modern
astronomy and folks like edward tufte
and others have said that he was the
first data scientist in that
through his evocative sketches and
drawings of the moon he not only
conveyed
data he conveyed emotion and senses
and really this this connection between
the retina
and the objects that he was depicting
and it was sort of news to me until i
read your book i'd heard this book by
this guy goff
that we'll get into in a little bit but
how galileo influenced
some of the modern thinking about
reality first can you say something
about galileo
and how did he contribute to our
sensation of reality
and as perceived by sensorial emotion
sensorial senses for lack of a better
word right
so galileo actually made a very
interesting distinction
between what later became called primary
and secondary qualities
um primary qualities would be things
that we think are part of objective
reality like
um maybe the shape of physical objects
the positions of physical objects in
space and time
and then so those would be primary and
in some sense those would be
real um and then there were things um
that were were called secondary
qualities
that galileo he didn't use that term but
but he was
pointing in this direction locke used
that term or where it's been used of
lock
and his his writings on this so things
like taste
and color in some sense you know
physicists might say
look an object really does have a shape
and a position
but it doesn't have a real color in fact
light doesn't have color it only has
say wavelengths and so in that sense
when you see color
color of something that that you make up
it's not really part of the
reality the reality in that case would
just be the wavelength of the light
and so galileo made made that
that interesting distinction that he
said some of the things that we perceive
are not the reality you know the real
reality
they're they're just our contribution
but but i think that galileo thought
that other things
like the positions and movements of
objects their masses and so forth
would be part of the objective reality
uh what
was later called primary qualities and
and the other thing that
i think many scientists would credit
galileo with was
he understood about the importance of
making very
careful experimental measurements even
about boring things i mean
he was rolling balls down inclined
planes and measuring how fast they moved
you might go
i mean if you're trying to understand
the big questions of the universe why
are you rolling balls down inclined
planes and measuring how fast they move
how
how far removed from the interesting
stuff is that but what galileo showed
was
by doing these very careful experiments
with great precision
and then trying to model mathematically
what you've what you've seen
you start to make serious progress on
the little things
that eventually are the road to the
bigger questions that you're interested
in maybe we don't care about balls on
inclined planes
but then we start learning about the
deep deep laws of nature
and then they start to open us up to new
ways of thinking about what's going on
and that's the big payoff
right and of course you know i've talked
about this in my book losing the nobel
prize that that galileo was deeply
influenced by the senses and in fact in
one of the passages that
toofty i think i'm pronouncing i never
know how to pronounce his name is that
right
there's a famous physicist at hooft uh
who won the nobel prize i'm trying to
get him on the end of the impossible
podcast
we'll see if that'll work out but
certainly to get tufti on would be uh
would be great as well but he calls it
uh you know in this passage where he
calls him the first
data scientist he uses this passage
about the pleiades
which are also known as the seven
sisters or subaru if you happen to speak
japanese
and this is a small asterism that we can
see tonight from anywhere in north
america
that is in the shoulder of taurus the
bull and these are uh really these
beautiful uh set of stars that are young
and hot and they're surrounded as
as hot young hollywood stars often are
by an entourage and this entourage is in
the form of a nebulosity
and galileo said uh by observing the
nebulosity he thought that those were
merely
uh unresolved stars that his telescope
was incapable of resolving
right if he could resolve it it proved
that by what he calls visible certainty
we have destroyed the arguments that
have for so long
vexed philosophers of previous
generations so first of all i love that
he's a physicist of course he has to uh
he has to like poke fun at philosophers
but secondly that something can be
proven visually
is a very perilous uh proposition in my
opinion
to what extent can we use perception uh
as a motivation for achieving scientific
proof or consensus whatsoever is it
not a fool's errand that's a great
question
because the evolutionary argument that i
just gave
says that the very language of our
visual perception and all of our senses
is the wrong language to describe
objective reality if that's of course
taking evolution by natural selection as
our starting point
that's just a theorem of that of that
theory we can of course argue about
evolution by natural selection and
whether we should think
that there's a deeper theory but but
granting evolution of natural selection
as our starting point
then what that theory entails is it's
not simply that we
maybe get the shape a little bit off or
the distances a little bit wrong
it's rather something much deeper and
that is that
evolution financial selection entails
that the very language of space and time
and position and momentum and frequency
and so forth is simply the wrong
language to describe objective reality
you couldn't possibly frame a true
description of objective reality
in those terms now now but to your
question
the that is the only language in which
we can actually
make experimental observations that's
that's what
we're equipped with and so what we have
to do
is go ahead and do experiments and
get data in the only language that we
can understand
but then we simply instead of assuming
that
that data and the way that we normally
would think about that data is just the
truth
we have to be a little bit more clever
we have to be like a person who's
wearing a a vr headset who's been
playing a video game
and they can just they can sort of you
know see like
say it's grand theft auto with the vr
souped-up version of it right
and and and you can start to ask
questions like is is the geometry of
this game a euclidean geometry and you
can start to do
work with some other friends who are you
know playing the game with you
and do some experiments and and discover
oh well this is a
roughly all euclidean geometry and and
do things like that
and that would be perfectly fine because
that's the only data that you can get is
within the language of the game but if
you think that that's going to take you
to uh an understanding of the deepest
reality
which in this metaphor would be the
circuits and software and voltages and
magnetic fields of some hidden
supercomputer that's running the game
well you're going to be sadly mistaken
and and wrong by thinking that you know
the euclidean geometry that you measured
in the game is going to tell you
something directly about the
supercomputer
that that's running the game you have to
think outside of the headset
and so that's what evolution by natural
selection is sort of telling us is that
yeah we can only get data in the headset
but how we interpret the data is going
to require us to think outside of the
confines of our headset outside of in
fact space and time itself
yeah and of course you know no one
really made the
same impact kind of relatively speaking
as galileo did on its predecessors
before we move off of him and on to
other you know slightly more modern than
the
16th and the 17th century conceptions of
of
sensorial perception i want to just
remind people listening
on a clubhouse that we're enjoying a
conversation with
renowned professor and thinker
philosopher scholar
professor don hoffman who i'm pleased to
call a colleague in this great wonderful
university that we call the university
of california
though we may be on separate campuses we
are colleagues in the world's greatest
university
uh don it's such a pleasure to be
affiliated with you i want to turn just
the last statement about galileo of
course he was involved in this
conception
and many of his books actually this is a
news break for
my friends listening on clubhouse uh my
uh subscribers on
youtube know this already but uh for
many years galileo's books were not
available
uh even though they were translated by
our colleague or our co-university
inhabitant stillman drake uh who was up
in uc berkeley for many years
and these translations of done by him
are the definitive ones of all time
including the dialogue on two chief
world systems which uh i always keep
nearby me
and uh and i started to uh to
investigate this book
and realize what an amazing writer
galileo is
and how beautiful and lyrical he does
right and i said well this is great but
you know this book is
539 pages long i wish i wish i could do
what i did with don hoffman's book
and listen to an audiobook version of it
wouldn't that be cool turns out
the audiobook version has never been
made and i
thought to myself well somebody's got to
do this for the maestro and and
why not let it be me and so i hooked
around and i and i found out
who has permission to do this and it was
the university of california press owns
the
rights to this translation so then i
thought well what could i do with it
and uh to make it kind of theatrical and
i said why don't i get my friend
carlo rovelli a previous guest on the
interview
podcast and he's going to narrate it
along with me and my colleague lucio
picharillo
and maybe someone like elena april or
andrea guezz
we got to get some some women in there
as well because of these italian women
especially elita april if you've ever
met her fabulous giannatti
is a hero of mine i would just love to
have an italian woman
narrate one of the three characters
anyway very cool
yeah so i'll keep you posted on that uh
that's great
labor of love uh maybe not uh yeah
remunetory
in the way that i would uh prefer it but
anyway it's not all about money
um but i do wanna say what galileo said
is he um
he talks about a wine's good taste does
not belong
to the objective determination of the
wine and hence of an object
even the object as an appearance but the
special character
is the sense in the subject who is
enjoying its taste
this is an argument that owes to the
namesake of the unit i don't know i
don't think it's the namesake of uc
berkeley
uh but that's george berkeley tell me a
little bit about george berkeley did he
not
come up with these ideas that you know
the moon does not exist except when
you're looking at it
except if you have sort of this god's
eye perspective talk about
berkeley is he is he irrelevant or is he
more relevant than ever
yes barkley had this very interesting
view
that everything that we perceive
is in some sense just a creation
of our senses uh and that
only he had a theological view he ended
up being a bishop in
the church but he had this view that
you know even if i'm not looking at a
tree it the tree exists only because
it's in
god's view so god keeps things existing
by
being by perceiving them but he said you
know
to be is to be perceived or to be a
perceiver
so that's a very very different point of
view than a physicalist view that says
uh to be is to be for example um
something in space and time with energy
and matter so that you know space time
energy and matter are the fundamental
natures of objective reality
and and barclay was saying no the
fundamental nature of
existence is being perceived or being a
perceiver
which which is a very different point of
view and it was you know
i think barkley was partly uh reacting
against what he thought were the um
the advances of a of a physicalist um
you know science that was mostly
materialist and and didn't
leave room perhaps for um other uh more
spiritual ideas
so when i look at uh these these kind of
uh
initial thoughts initial forays in that
time of course what galileo was railing
against
back in the dialogue uh was the notion
that the earth was stationary
and uh he said don't you know your
senses
tell you that that it's stationary and
it seemed like he's sort of arguing
against himself because sometimes
they'll say the senses
can teach you everything and and you can
have visible certainty in other words
you could prove something cuades
demonstratum
uh based on visual accused and visual
evidence on the other hand he could say
like don't trust your sensory
motion perception and i think it's so
interesting that you connect and you
mentioned this
early on in the book you talk about the
grand questions
and i think of them as sort of um
chicken or egg problems in other words
how the universe come from non-universe
how did uh matter come from energy how
did life come from
matter and all of which you know darwin
you know sort of presuppose
was a crazy thing to ever think about
now we know it as big bang nuclear
synthesis
and then lastly how does consciousness
emerge from you know bacteria how do you
go from
uh bacteria to bach or um uh
you know anything like that and you talk
about the survey in science magazine
arguably the number one or two journal
in the world
2006 asked what are the big questions
for the next century
the number one of course i pat myself on
the back hurting my shoulder
uh was uh what of what is the universe
made and then number two was how does
biology produce consciousness
in my uh yeah and my expertise at least
in thinking about this
i don't know if we'll ever have an
answer uh you know of what the universe
has made
or what predated our universe these are
active subjects of of
um of debate and scientific inquiry is
it true in biology that this
is still considered a plausible possible
outcome that
biology could predict how consciousness
emerges
i would say among my peers in cognitive
neuroscience
the those who of my colleagues
their brilliant colleagues of mine who
are working on this i would say that 95
99 of them take it for granted
that in human beings and other animals
conscious experiences are a product of
brain activity
um and we just have to figure out what
kind of brain activity causes which
kinds of brain experiences and
what kinds of conscious experiences and
how that happens i mean there are
theories for example that say
roger penrose for example and stuart
hameroff together have a theory that
says that
certain structures called microtubules
and neurons have
certain electrons with special quantum
states and
if you can get an orchestrated collapse
of these
quantum states using some of penrose's
ideas about
gravitational collapses of quantum
states
you get the right orchestrated collapse
of these quantum states then
that will cause conscious experiences
that's what consciousness is
others say that no it's more like the
architecture of
how information is passed through the
nervous system through the brain
certain information that's broadcast
widely
is going to be conscious information
that's sort of
stuck in certain parts of the
architecture and isn't
widely available throughout the entire
system will not be conscious but if it's
broadcast widely it will be so this is
the
so-called global neuronal workspace uh
theory
bernard bars and other are involved in
in this
and then there's one that says um well
it's more like
sort of causal computational
architectures that nervous systems or or
other physical systems might have this
is integrated
information theory it says if you have
the right causal computational
architecture
then it has something called you know
high integration
of information they call it fee high
integrated information but
called fee then that will lead to
or or b conscious experience and so so
the idea is a
a reductionist idea you start with
space-time and matter and physical
objects
and then you have to show from those
foundations how consciousness
emerges and and that's part of a bigger
picture of which you're far
better aware than me which is the big
bang cosmology
and the idea is that you at the big bang
there was
only space time and energy and matter um
there was no life and there was and so
that took hundreds of millions maybe
billions of years before life came
around
and then who knows how much longer after
that before consciousness came around
so surely it must be that consciousness
emerges from space time and matter
and so that's why most of my colleagues
are reductionist in this way
the payoff or or perhaps the adjacency
of the problem
often comes up in what i do which is
sometimes works to our detriment and
i'll say
you know we do get this sort of fear or
concern for lack of a better word that
you have
uh you know being too close to the woo
side of things and science is never a
good good thing and in fact
you know i was going to play a game with
you but i don't have time to do it which
would be
you know what i call high and low where
we take the highest verified review on
amazon of this book and the lowest
verified review on
amazon and we compare them and uh but
i'll spare you it but the but the
problem is the the lowest
i mean it's got 500 five star reviews
the only
you know one star review that i can find
that really you know is kind of
criticizing it says
well oh really you have deepak chopra i
guess on the printed book i listen to
the audiobook version
but the printed book has you know deepak
chopra's industry i know you guys have
worked together
he's been a guest on my show two or
three times uh already
and uh he's also contributed to the
endorsement and comey
on a book uh by frank wilczyk who you
may know won the nobel prize in 2014.
and these are and he's commented on his
book so uh
so the the criticisms oh how could you
have deepak chopra i don't know if the
guy even read it
um but but the bottom line is is is it
sometimes the case that these
that these books run the danger of being
too close to
maybe science fiction or this notion of
the mind of god and we can understand
the mind of god
i've seen this a lot with even in this
book you know to give the
uh the devil his due uh whoever wrote
that one star review
a plethora of references to the matrix i
see that in many books including
galileo's error this book by goff that
we might get a chance to talk about
um so what do you think about this and
the notion that comes usually
concomitantly with it
of pan psychism which is uh maybe you
could describe what is panpsychism
is it wu is it adjacent what do you
think
right well this is a very important
question and the
the one thing i would say is that you
know as scientists
uh we get our ideas in many many
different places
casual conversations a glass of beer
reading a paper it's all over the place
but what we do as scientists is we then
take them and we have to be very precise
in writing them down as mathematical uh
precise theories and then we go test
them so so my attitude is i mean i i
talk with people from
from all sorts of areas and all sorts of
religious
and scientific fields and i get ideas
wherever i
i can and of course i'm i'm critical of
the ideas i'm critical of my ideas
you know that's just the way science
works so get your ideas wherever you
want to what makes
science different is that no matter
where you get the ideas now you've got
to make them mathematically precise
you've got to make testable predictions
and then you've got to go out and test
them so that's where you get away from
the woo
it doesn't matter where you get the
ideas the question is what do you do
with them and how rigorously
do you frame them and test them once
you've gotten them and so that's
that's the key the key point for me now
in pan psychism
the reason why pan psychism and several
other ideas have been
starting to catch favor among cognitive
neuroscientists and philosophers
studying consciousness
is that the physicalist
approach even though it seems to
be well motivated by the standard
reductionist framework in which space
time is fundamental start at the big
bang and so forth
it seems to have all the right pedigree
in the right framework
we've not been able to solve
a single specific conscious experience
all the theories i gave you orchestrated
collapse of microtubules
integrated information theory global
workspace if you ask these
brilliant researchers some of them are
good friends of mine
just ask them as i do sometimes on stage
at get conferences
great great theory so what what specific
experience can you
tell me what's the integrated
information for the taste of vanilla
or the smell of chocolate or whatever
you want and they can't give one
so the weird thing about it is that
no physicalist theory of consciousness
to date can explain even one specific
conscious experience let's say
this is the particular causal
computational architecture
the right integrated information that
must be the taste of vanilla it could
not be the the taste of chocolate and
these are the exact reasons why
and if you made this particular change
to the causal architecture it wouldn't
necessarily change it into the smell of
a rose
there's just nothing like that on the
table and and and the hard thing is that
that it's not like we go oh well but we
can see how we could do it
we actually don't see how we could make
that connection what how are you going
to go from a causal computational
architecture or a global
you know broadcasting to that must be
the smell of of a rose how do you do
that without
a big leap and so that's been a big big
problem so
this is then that was one thing that led
me to
begin to question the whole reductionist
framework and to ask evolution i mean
is that you know maybe space time and
matter and objects aren't the
fundamental nature of reality and
an evolution come back comes back and
says they aren't
that's the wrong language but in pan
psychism now what we have is a move to
try to come at things at a different
tack
the idea is if you can't
boot up consciousness from space-time
and matter
maybe you can somehow get consciousness
coming in
as a primary concept now it
there's two ways that this is done one
one is a
monist way in which you say okay let's
just start with consciousness as the
only thing that there is so we have a
mathematical model of consciousness
on its own terms and we have to then
show how space time and matter emerge
or you can have a more of a of a duelist
kind of
version where you say let's let's say
that there's um
physical stuff and a structure and also
consciousness and have
them somehow interact the way
pan cyclists work is they there are many
versions of it so i'll pick the one that
i think is the most common
version it says look
physics gives us these equations for how
matter
operates and how the world works but it
doesn't tell us
what's inside the equations it's just
it's just how things operate but it
doesn't tell us what the intrinsic
nature of those things
is so maybe when we talk about the wave
equation of electron
maybe that you know that equation is
just
how something behaves but it's not
telling us what it is that behaves what
is
an electron really or what's inside the
electron and so pancyto says well maybe
there's some
consciousness there maybe what's really
going on inside electron is that there's
some consciousness
and so so the idea is that the certain
particles or certain combinations of
particles like
maybe a a neutron which has you know
three quarks in it
that that might be conscious as well so
quarks are conscious or have
consciousness
three quarks together can make a proton
or a neutron and and those are conscious
but some combinations like the things
that go into making a rock maybe that's
the wrong kind of combination and so a
rock
isn't conscious and so so the idea there
is to
me it can be run in a dualist version
sometimes they call it a neutral monist
version it's it's a little slippery
i i tend to think of it somewhat as as
dualist but
but i think others who are pan cyclists
might disagree
but the key point is that there's you
take the laws of physics
and where you find an entity like an
electron or a proton or something like
that
you can put consciousness as the
intrinsic thing that's actually
being governed by those equations
now i myself am not a pan psychist i i
don't think that that approach at least
the one i just described
is is radical enough i think that
there are good reasons on physics
grounds
to think that space time itself is
doomed that space time is not
fundamental
that that physics even if they are not
interested in consciousness
per se um that physics itself
has to look for something deeper than
space-time and
this is worked by neymar connie hamed
and other physicists who
who will give arguments from you know
gravity and this interaction with
quantum theory that that say that
you know you there are no local
observables in space-time
there's just no it cannot be fundamental
and they're looking for deeper
structures they're finding things like
amplitude the sociohedron cosmological
polytopes
that are deeper structures that that
have no hilbert spaces so there's no
quantum theory
they have no locality uh no lorenzen
variants
themselves so they don't care about
locality and space time
but they nevertheless they have deep
structures that can give rise to for
example scattering
amplitudes they can predict scattering
amplitudes and they can
they can be projected into space time
and show you how you get
locality and unitarily so so so the
the pan cyclist views i think are are
too limited
they typically take the current
space-time laws of physics
as foundational and are trying to stick
consciousness into the interest issues
there
and i think the physicists themselves
are telling us when they're going for
things like the amplitude
look there's a whole new level of of
logic and structure that we need to look
for outside of spacetime
yeah i should say of course to listeners
so we're talking with professor donald
hoffman
renowned philosopher cognitive scientist
and
deep thinker author of the current book
we're talking about today
is the case against reality uh which
makes astonishing claims
not unrelated to the astonishing
hypothesis of francis crick to which we
will soon turn
i do want to see if there are any
questions uh first in clubhouse i see
there's at least one hand
that is raised and maybe two so let's
get them
up on stage cami if you could get them
up there so don we're going to put the
phone up to
uh to the microphone and uh we'll take a
question first from
heron erin do you have a question for dr
hoffman
well it wasn't actually a question it
was just a quick uh
observation if that's acceptable sure if
it's quick
yeah as i see it i only have available
to me my immediate sensory experience
and stories about my immediate sensory
experience the very idea of reality
is a linguistic construction is a story
an
attempt to make sense of my sensory
experience which is
completely mysterious all the theories
that talk about perception and that
there being something outside
responsible for constructing my
perception
those are stories and they may be
interesting stories and even useful
stories but
they're no more than stories reality is
a story
i'll leave it at that any reaction don
yes uh none of us knows for sure what
objective reality might be and and
there is some there are some
philosophers like emmanuel kant who
said look there's the pneumonia and the
phenomena the phenomena of what we can
experience what we can measure
what we can do empirical science with
and the pneumona he can't at least in
some interpretations of khan said
um that's the objective reality but
there's nothing that really we can say
about it it's beyond
um the realm of what we can do you know
science about and
of course for for scientists you know i
i
want to try to give a theory of
objective reality i want that's what we
do is we
we tend to be uh realist about our
theories in the sense that we're
we're proposing things that we think
might be true descriptions of objective
reality
kant might be right there maybe the
pneumonia the the reality
um may be beyond anything that humans
can ever
approach and there's a a book by john
westerhoff
which uh where he makes an argument
there there is no
objective reality uh so so
but i myself um
in the framework of evolution by natural
selection
that theory does posit
an objective reality as part of the
framework of the theory
and payoff functions are mappings from
that objective reality
into payoff values and so in that
framework what i can say is
if there is some kind of objective
reality
and it has some structure then
evolution by natural selection that
theory entails the probability of zero
that we see any of that structure
now that doesn't entail though that we
don't have the conceptual systems to try
to think outside of our
sensory headset right the virtual
reality that evolution gave us
we may have the conceptual capacity to
think outside of the box of our senses
and try to get um you know
understandings of the structure of
objective reality
just like for example i can't imagine a
specific color i've never seen before
right if you say if i ask you
think of a specific color imagine a
concrete color that you've never seen
before
well i mean nothing happens smoke comes
out of my ears nothing happens
and and yet i do have the conceptual
capacity to
imagine that there could be colors that
i could never
see and to imagine for example if i'm a
male dichromate
that maybe these people that that are
trichromats maybe they really are seeing
colors that i could never even
concretely imagine
and so so it's it's certainly seems
legitimate to say that even though my
sensory system can't reveal this thing
to me directly
my cognitive systems can help me go
where my senses
might fail and so i think a lot of
scientists take that attitude about this
thing
but but my answer bottom line is who
knows what reality is
right even if our theories work and pass
every test that doesn't mean they're
right so we can never know for sure
if we've got it that's right and i want
to turn to that next uh
especially this notion of itp which
is in stands for interface theory of
perception
which uh which something that that you
coined and i want to understand
how we can we can think of it when you
say interface you literally mean a type
of interface
and and the question is in in what way
is it a description of reality
is one way is it an analogy which i'm
not even denying the validity or
necessity of an analogy in this case but
to what extent is it real i mean we'll
get to nima
and stuff later who hopefully will be
coming on the podcast shortly um
but the the question of of you know is
it an analogy
which has utility to help us visualize
things or is it itself this infinite
turtles all the way down and
and you're just like substituting one uh
description of something uh
undescribable for another
well i would say first if i just think
in terms of the framework of evolution
by natural selection just
the the logical framework of that theory
what that theory entails is
that there it assumes that there's an
objective reality it assumes that there
are organisms that
are being shaped uh with sensory systems
and
the theory then says that it's a theorem
of that theory
that the sensory systems will not
ever reveal true structures of that
objective reality instead
they will give you sensory systems that
serve
only as guides to adaptive behavior
so you're not the whole point is not to
see the truth
the whole point is to stay alive long
enough to reproduce
that's that's so that's the structure of
evolutionary theory
so so once you understand that sensory
systems are not
windows on the truth they're merely
guides to adaptive behavior
then then i say well you know people
then ask
well how could that possibly be you know
help me understand and i think
that's when the metaphor of a virtual
reality headset
or a user interface on your laptop those
are the kinds of metaphors i think
help us to understand what the
mathematics of evolution is
is telling us like when you use your
laptop you're writing a paper or a book
or something like that and the icon for
the
book on your desktop is blue and
rectangular in the middle of your screen
it doesn't mean that the book in the
computer is blue and rectangular in the
middle of your computer somehow
i mean there's no mapping like that
between your senses
and the objective reality instead what
you see on your laptop
hides the truth and that's why it's
valuable
you don't want to see the voltages and
magnetic fields and the circuits and
software i mean if you had to toggle
voltages to write your book good luck
you you'd never finish your book
and so that's what evolution did it it
gives us a user interface now that part
is
now i'm just using a metaphor i mean for
whatever what evolution has given us but
it's given us a user interface
that hides the truth but lets us control
the truth whatever that truth might be
in a simple way using simple user
interface uh icons
and you know when i think about that um
that that fruitful metaphor that you're
using
i i can't help but escape the fact that
we are talking
on clubhouse simultaneously uh friends
are tweeting out
it will be recorded on uh on youtube
it will have a uh it will have a
lifelong presence perhaps uh forever but
you know there's a distinction i hope to
get you on
uh on on clubhouse by the end of this
conversation or teach you how to get on
as i have so many people before because
so many people did it for me
but what's nice about clubhouse is
purely audio so you just drop in listen
i'm gonna take more questions uh we're
speaking with professor donald hoffman
you see irvine
friend and colleague and uh and and
really a titan of this field
with novel innovative and testable ideas
and that's what i think is so
draws me to what you do and and we might
disagree about you know certain aspects
of it of course you are
uh far more eminent in this domain but
what's interesting about clubhouse
is that it's a very low bandwidth thing
i mean only i can talk or only you can
talk or only one of my
uh the people that are up on stage or
soon will be can talk so
it's a single channel so to speak
whereas twitter we can read really fast
we can
perceive information really fast read
hundreds of words per minute
i always say like some of the people
probably some people that are listening
to us
right now wish there was a 2x speed
uh for clubhouse the way there is for uh
listening to podcast uh but
you and i speak pretty quickly so i i
think i think we're doing okay
but um but the bottom line is clubhouse
acts as a filter
in a certain sense and it is almost as
important what information we choose to
discard
as the information that we choose to get
past the filter
and so you're arguing that evolution is
designed adaptive filters we call them
pid proportional integral derivative
feedback circuits etc but there's always
a lossiness to any filtration system
and i wonder in the evolutionary
framework
um you know there are some things that
it's clear that we derive pleasure from
them but it's not clear that it's a
fitness boosting as a metric uh
for example music when i'm listening to
music i'm perceiving there's
tons of things that are going on or or
and i smell a smell
that might be more easy to see what the
purpose is because maybe it reminds me
that it's dangerous to ingest that
but where there's music where it doesn't
seem like there's a fitness payoff
in the human i agree in birds and whales
probably i don't know i'm not a
biologist
uh but but the point is what is the
purpose evolutionarily speaking of this
most
august you know kind of uh uh trait of
the human species to make music
for no purpose whatsoever it seemed
biologically wasteful
at least from a novice perspective like
mine right
uh so evolutionary psychologists have
thought a lot about this
stephen pinker has has got some good
ideas he calls a music
um auditory cheesecake it's you know
something that
uh cheesecake sort of hits our senses
in a very very strong way all the
positive things right we
in some sense in the case of taste we
you know
fatty foods are really good for us they
have high calories sugary foods are
really good for us they
we need the energy and so forth and in
during the pleistocene it was hard for
us to get these things
and so if we find a food like cheesecake
that has
all of them um you would never find
perhaps cheesecake
during the pleistocene but now that we
can make it it hits all the things that
were
shaped by evolution during the
pleistocene and so so we go for it
in the case of auditory stuff um we
do use auditory information to tell us
um for example who's attractive some
people's voices
are more attractive than others and that
will have some correlation with the
reproductive fitness of that person
so you know the the voice of a 99 year
old
um has certain qualities to it that are
different from the voice of a 21 year
old and we pick up on those qualities
and we can infer something about the age
of the person
and that in terms of reproductive
potential then
leads to certain attraction or or not
and so
those kinds of arguments can can be
given for
why we find certain patterns of auditory
um
stimulation more attractive than others
because they
in the past and in the present are are
correlated with
um with reproductive potential and and
and fitness enhancement so in music now
what what happens is
just like with with you know cheesecake
you start to
someone figures out how to put all these
wonderful ingredients together
and you get something that you would
never perhaps ever heard in nature
but now it's like cheesecake which would
never exist in nature until we put all
these ingredients together so
that may be one aspect of it but there
may be more also to music in the sense
of a social
um cooperative
and bonding experience that comes from
music
so so again you know tribes in our
evolutionary past
often when they went out to hunt or
fight would have some kind of
um chanting or music together so it
could be a bonding thing so
so i would say that from an evolutionary
point of view from evolutionary
psychology
the kind of question that you you ask
brian is is a non-trivial one
but we we have ideas about how to try to
come to
rigorous answers yeah um so now i want
to take another question uh from the
audience i have a friend of mine mark
lovett who is a uh a very deep thinker
he is up in the
and the stage in clubhouse mark do you
have a a comment or question
for dr hoffman you know how are humans
supposed to
interact with you know the real
quote-unquote world
if our memory is so flawed and our
ability to comprehend reality
um just doesn't work so well that would
be my question
great great question and and and i would
say
my own attitude is is
i i certainly agree that we don't see
reality as it is that our beliefs
are not necessarily the truth and i take
that as a welcome
wake up i i don't find it discouraging
at all
it's it's a wonderful realization
it's like someone that's had a vr
headset on all their life
and they thought that the virtual world
that they were in was the fundamental
reality
and you finally tell them you know what
everything that you've seen is just a
virtual reality headset and i'm about to
take the headset off
well that's that's good news so
science has the tools to
try to go beyond just what our senses
tell us um and and so i think that
you know we can never know if we've
succeeded but we don't have to give up
so
i think this is a fabulous time actually
in the sciences science i would say from
this point of view from an evolutionary
point of view
for the since galileo we've been
sharpening our tools by understanding
our headset
so we've really learned how to use
experimental and mathematical tools
we've studied
our headset we we really have done it
so well that our theories are now so
good
evolution of natural selection quantum
field theory and gravity are so good
that they tell us
space time is not fundamental they're
telling us you've been studying the
headset
that's an incredible vindication of
science it's telling us
that even though you assumed that you
were looking at the truth uh you're not
you're just looking at a headset
but now use those same tools to try to
come up with theories
beyond space and time and the
way that you test those ideas
is to take make them mathematically
precise so
like what nema is doing with the with
his structures outside of spacetime like
the amplitude or something like that
make them mathematically rigorous show
exactly how they project into space-time
and see the predictions that they make
there and if you can then you can test
them
you can you only see things in your
headset so that's where the experiments
have to be done in your headset
but you can still test models outside
the headset as long as you have a
mathematical model about how they
project into the headset
so that's what science is now going to
be up to we're taking our first forays
out of our headset out of space and time
and science is up to the task so
this is a for me an exciting opportunity
and and not a time to be
um discouraged very good
a question from my friend and
collaborator
in all i should point out by the way don
do you know that galileo
actually invented an actual vr
or ar headset which was a type of uh
chronograph
that was based on a telescope a
telescope looking at the moons of
jupiter
so you'd wear this helmet and you'd look
at the moons of jupiter
and it would have a telescope built into
it and you'd
augment your reality or vision in this
case
and you'd be able to see the moons and
this is a huge problem back in the 1600s
to tell time and in fact he was impelled
by the desire that impels many of us
professors to make money
and to capitalize on no i'm just kidding
uh we're not all
don i shouldn't i shouldn't accuse him
of my own venal motivations but galileo
had this uh
vr headset that he put on i had a
telescope and uh he didn't win the
longitude prize
but uh but eventually uh it was per it
was
it was and is used to do many other some
say more important things like
test and measure the speed of light and
its constancy throughout our solar
system
uh i didn't know that that's wonderful
yeah a question from
uh max of bitbull who is a colleague of
mine dr
max would you like to ask dr hoffman a
question
the question was is consciousness a
unique filter into reality or is it just
our filter well
so the answer is i don't know but i can
just tell you how
i'm thinking about this um in cognitive
neuroscience
we have this problem of consciousness we
call it the hard problem of
consciousness which is how our
our experience of you know taste of
chocolate smell of garlic
sound of a trumpet how are these
conscious experiences related to neural
activity in the brain or perhaps to
circuits and software in an ai system
and we've come up empty
trying to start with the physical
systems and boot up consciousness
we've just come up empty we can't i mean
i'm not saying we can't do it but we
we've had very very bright people
including nobel prize winners many of
them
working on this and we've come up empty
so far and and
it seems to me to be principled
that we can't start with space time and
matter and boot up consciousness and so
there's two responses one is to say well
there's no such thing as consciousness
it's just an illusion so dan dennett and
keith frankish will say this and
of course then they have to explain how
the illusion of consciousness arises
right so how do i
what is the brain activity that causes
the illusion of the taste of vanilla so
there is no such thing as the conscious
experience of the taste of
vanilla but nevertheless somehow our
brain has duped us into having
the illusion of the taste of vanilla so
they still owe us a mathematically
precise theory about
what are the neural processes precisely
that lead to the illusion of the taste
of vanilla and why those processes could
not be the illusion of the sound of a
trumpet so and
and there's nothing there yet but
there's the other approach i'm taking
um now to get to your question i don't
view consciousness as a filter
but i'm saying if if i don't start with
space time and matter
maybe i can start with consciousness not
as an emergent
property of space-time but as an entity
that i want to
mathematically model on its own terms so
i want a
simple mathematical structure that i
claim captures everything there is to
claim
to capture fundamentally about
consciousness
and i want to look then at the
mathematical implications of that
formalism
and then show that somehow there's this
dynamics of consciousness
and that can give rise to space time so
space time
is not fundamental in any sense and and
scale
structure and space-time is in no way
fundamental to consciousness that
consciousness itself
is fundamental my attitude is very much
like turing when he was trying to come
up with a theory of computation right
computation is a wild and woolly
enterprise there's a
traveling salesman problem computing pi
there's np complete problem there's tons
of stuff in computation
touring managed to find this drop dead
trivial formalism
a finite set of states a halt state a
start state a set of transition rules
and and
that turned out to be enough to you know
have the church during thesis anything
that's computable can be computed by a
turing machine
i want the same thing for consciousness
a minimal formalism
that has combinatorial properties that
can allow me to build a theory of
anything
that i want to have about consciousness
the self learning memory problem solving
intelligence i want to build all those
things
from a stripped down version of
conscience so that's the attitude in
which i'm
thinking about it consciousness from
this point of view isn't
like just a filter it's the whole thing
um
now again i'm probably wrong but i'm
just telling you the strategy
that i'm taking i don't want to start
with space time and matter because that
doesn't seem to work
so let me start with consciousness and
see if i can boot that up
so yeah i should say i had
all right who was that um not yet
in just a minute yeah hold on um thanks
dean um so yeah speaking of ch
uh of turing we had a gnome chomsky on
the into the impossible podcast over the
summer
and noam was saying uh things you know
that uh you know turing considered
certain questions such as you know can
machines think is like
utterly ridiculous and that brings up
one of these notions that i want to talk
to you about
which is you know this this notion of
increasing copy
uh computational ability quantum
computing etc whereas
nema's uh theories and he hasn't uh he
has agreed to come on the end of the
impossible podcast and we'll talk to him
about uh his his theories i would say
are
of course he's incredibly brilliant very
creative and inventive but
they're by no means mainstream they're
by no means accepted at the same
level of most of the other physics
content of this book the case against
reality so i just
want to caution people that because nema
is conjecturing it doesn't necessarily
mean
it's it's established fact or even
accepted
by even a majority of physicists even
though it has it has some promise
and and i would say you know there are
alternatives loop quantum gravity
even string theory et cetera that are
trying to parameterize the the
uh fundamental you know dichotomy
between
space-time as fundamental or emergent a
primitive or somehow elementary versus
not being so so the question i have is
about uh conscious computers so
uh not only let's just skip touring and
say chomsky's wrong
turns are uh you know can computers be
conscious
if if uh i don't see why not according
you know at least
if i put on my naive panpsychism hat i
don't know why not anything you know
just silicon and and uh or joseph's
injunctions or whatever so can they
be conscious and if they are and if we
are you know somehow a virtual
pursuit perception or perceiving
entities
uh then who's to say that we're not
simulated as people have
conjectured and i'm sure that'll
generate some follow-up questions from
from the audience yeah so go ahead yeah
great question so there are a couple of
frameworks to try to answer that
in a physicalist framework so space time
and matter are fundamental
then the attitude is that of course
machines can be conscious
the brain is a machine and it's
conscious so so we have a first-hand
example so uh john cyril at
uc berkeley has made that argument and i
think like
99 of my colleagues in cognitive
neuroscience say of course
right brains are machines they're
carbon-based machines not silicon-based
machines but they're machines
and they create consciousness and we
just have to work out how how it's done
and and they may be right that so in
that case yes and if that's true
then i would say absolutely if
carbon-based machines can create
conscious then
then certainly there's nothing against
silicon-based machines
now i've argued though that there's
principal reasons why you can't start
with uh inanimate matter and boot up
consciousness
that i i think it just can't be done and
that the whole
big bang cosmology has to be re-thought
in that regard and maybe start with
consciousness being fundamental
now in the case of panpsychism uh once
again
the panpsychism has consciousness in
some sense being fundamental it's not
derived from matter
but it's sort of the heart of of matter
it's it's the
uh to use hawking's phrases the the fire
inside the equations right that that
that's that's what consciousness is
so in that sense surely the right kinds
of machines will have the right kinds of
pan psychic
consciousness so that's a second
framework in which you can
can think about it the wrong kind of
machine is a rock right
it has the wrong kind of architecture so
the combinatorial
way in which atoms combine to make a
rock is not the right kind of
combinatorics to have
the rock have its own special
consciousness of its own kind that's
above and beyond all the consciousnesses
of the particles so that's the
sort of the combination issue that comes
up in pan psychism certain combinations
will have
consciousness associated with them
others will not and so you have to be
precise about that and and pan cyclists
are are struggling to to do that
in the framework that i'm working on
consciousness
is fundamental um so
it's not arising in any way from physics
instead physics and space-time is just
the headset
that certain consciousnesses use so the
the metaphor i like to give is
the twitter person the vast social
network of interacting
um agents in the twitterverse there's
tens of millions of users billions of
tweets
there's no way that any twitter user can
grapple with the whole thing and read
all the tweets
so we have visualization tools for vast
social data
that's overwhelming we have
visualization tools and so
in this view in which i'm proposing that
ultimate reality is a vast social
network of interacting consciousnesses
like the twitterverse so that's the
fundamental reality
then spacetime is just one
headset one kind of data structure one
visualization tool that
certain of the agents use to help them
grok or interact with other agents now
once we under if we think about it that
way i need to write down a mathematical
model of
of the dynamics of these agents
of the headset the mapping of the
dynamics of conscious agents
into the headset once i've done that
then we can try to reverse engineer that
mapping and say
the headset is there to give me contact
with certain conscious agents or to give
me trends
about what these conscious agents are
doing just like you get trends in
in twitter so the question would be
could i
once i know how this space-time headset
works
can i open new portals in that headset
to new consciousnesses and with some of
those portals the technology
needed to make those portals look like
silicon and circuits
and my answer is probably
i mean it's probably possible once we
understand
the headset we can reverse engineer it
right right now my headset when i see
your face
i've got a portal into your
consciousness fallible but genuine
portal into your consciousness
so we know that this headset under this
framework gives us portals into
consciousness
could we have a precise enough
understanding of this
headset and of his relationship to
conscious agents that we could reverse
engineer
i think yes and i think some of the
technology may look like
artificial intelligence but we wouldn't
be doing it in a reductionist framework
we're not starting with circuits and
software
that are unconscious and booting up
consciousness we're starting with
consciousness
and a headset that's been constructed by
conscious agents we're reverse
engineering it to open up new portals to
other conscious agents so it's a
completely different framework you talk
a lot in the book about
experience and i've been thinking about
a quote i heard from sam harris once
which was
which is something to do with um you
know that the most valuable
quantity in life isn't time you know
because
time we waste everyone says you know
money is so valuable no you can
make money back but you can't make time
back you know if i ask you don
you know could you would you like to
trade this last two hours of of your
generosity
i say yeah give me that back i'd love to
have that time back to play with my uh
my friends and do whatever i want but
but in reality it's actually
according to sam harris's attention
right so you have a certain amount of
attention
and that's the most conserved quantity
because we all have time to watch
you know lord knows i've watched a lot
of cat videos but i've been thinking a
lot about it and i
and i can't i can't help but ask you in
the remaining minutes
before we wrap up um and i want to ask
you something
i actually think the most valuable
precious commodity is innocence
because i have a bunch of kids and i'm
so
amazed by their learning and their
growth every day and
when i see something like time or even
attention
uh it's it's reversible in the sense
that like okay so you could rejuvenate
if you're really drained or okay so you
you did all this you wasted all this
time
you know eating and watching the super
bowl but now you can go for a run but
in a sense you really can you really
can't get back and
and i see that and i've talked to i've
talked to men who've gone to war
and and and how to take lives of the
enemy
and they said they can never undo that
and that was the biggest loss of their
innocence it wasn't the drugs that they
did it was
and so i caution people um and i've had
addicts on the show and i've had
people uh that really opened up in ways
i never thought i was talking about
physics all of a sudden this guy tells
me that
you know he's had to kill people in his
life in service of his country and
it breaks my heart because i know he's a
good soul and i'm not condemning it at
all
and there are listeners right now in
this room who have been to war
and and then i i've heard people that
have been drug addicts and and i know
that the last comment you know is not
maybe you know to do anything
really hurt yourself but is there
irreversibility
i mean am i doing some sort of child
abuse to my kids and i i actually just
tell them i'm like
you do these drugs it's it's
irreversible and i'm talking about my
experience my children my experience my
life there are things that you know we
always talk about
how you know well i wouldn't have been
the person i was today
if x y and z didn't happen to me and
actually i've i've looked at this and
all the guests i've had on 116 guests
now 117 with dons
gracing us on the on the podcast uh but
uh
but you know thinking about you know
kind of the experiences and yeah i
wouldn't trade anything
i wouldn't you know i i am the result of
all my experiences in a certain sense
but again i'm just asking don you know
from a from a neurochemical perspective
uh are there way is there you know a
possibility that that certain drugs are
not um are one-way ratchets and paul's
in in the fine mannion sense that it can
only go in one direction
and people like me perhaps uh
shouldn't shouldn't try it uh by the way
i might have a more addictive
personality
uh i know i have addiction to food and
i'm addicted to love
uh but but the point i'm trying to make
down is is there are there drug
experiences that you really can't come
back from
yes i think that there are some of
course that are that may open your mind
and be
harmless and others that could be irr
irreversible and there's going to be
individual differences so
you know you are taking a a chance just
like if you have dinner
and eat mushrooms you're taking a chance
too right to me some my friends that
eating a mushroom was fine for me but
for them it's it's irreversible so
so there are we are taking these chances
i think you know
having a hit of marijuana is probably
not going to if i did that it would
it would have no long-term effects on me
and my
the benefits my outweigh the the the
risks um
and i have good friends who have done
many many trips on on five
and uh are you know are psychonauts they
they just really go out there and they
come back and they tell me all sorts of
interesting things
and right now my attitude is um i i hear
what you're saying and
i you know i don't need to go there
right now myself
to do the work that i'm doing that's
trying to put
um structure and and um mathematical
understanding to the kinds of things
that you're you're talking about
um but you know others disagree uh you
know my good friend annika harris
um suggests that i would be in better
shape and better able to move forward on
on these ideas if i had first hand
experience
i do i should say i do meditate quite a
bit i've meditated for 18 years and so
i do let go of all thought i go into
silence
and i do explore outside of the geeky
realm in that way
um and but there i don't feel like i'm
very much in danger of injuring my brain
very good so i'm gonna need to wrap it
up
um in just a second or two i want to
just reiterate we're talking to dr
donald hoffman who's professor at uc
irvine just up the road
and uh and and really an influence um
so uh so i want to just finish up with
uh just one of the questions that i
normally ask my
uh my guests who honor me by their
presence
and uh and that is you know sort of
advice to your former self the name of
this podcast
the into the impossible podcast and that
comes from arthur c clarke who you quote
in this book the very famous line any
sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic and that
is uh how i open every one of these
podcasts as you'll find out when you
listen to the audio version of it
uh his second law is that for every
expert there's an equal and
opposite expert and the third law and we
all know that in the faculty club i'd
love to
have to drop that little humdinger on
people uh but the uh the last
uh law that derives uh the the
derivation of the name of this podcast
is the only way of determining the
limits
of the possible is to venture beyond
them
into the impossible i want to ask you
don advice to your former self
um if you could go back in time and tell
a 20 year old 30 year old donald hoffman
one piece of advice
that would give him the courage to
venture into the impossible as you have
done
maybe enabling something new and at an
earlier phase in your life
what would that piece of wisdom or
advice be well i'd tell myself a couple
things because i think there's a couple
things i needed to know that i didn't
know one is
um listen to authorities
but be willing after you've really
studied them
to argue against them vociferously
so don't don't be stupid and not listen
listen but then have the confidence to
argue against them and second
learn as much mathematics as you
possibly can
right i mean that's that is for for
for a theorist um
translating your abstract ideas into
something that you can
really use and make predictions from is
is a precious gift right now i have to
work with mathematicians
who who are kind enough to collaborate
with me and
and deal with my you know relative lack
of mathematical expertise so i
have good collaborators i would love to
i would have gone back and said
you'll get a master's degree at least in
mathematics while you're doing all this
other stuff so you'll have
so you can work more on your own on the
mathematical side so
so be brave of course listen to the
experts but then
go and follow your own dreams and your
own ideas
um but also be humble about it right you
know don't be dog-headed and dogmatic
about it that's
i mean that's how you stop inquiry so be
dogmatic about nothing be
open about everything and learn
mathematics
very good i think that'll be the title
of the show i want to thank everybody
but especially i want to thank
dr donald hoffman i'm pleased to and
proud to have you as a colleague in the
university of california system
please find his ted talk on youtube it's
got 1.57 million views
uh on just youtube alone find his
website for his book the case against
reality which is so fascinating
i really found so much in there that i
just could talk to you for hours what i
want to do next is have a conversation
with you and nima akane ahmed
uh who will uh hopefully we won't team
up too much against the u.s physicist
but then we'd have on your side we'll
have maybe uh dr stewart hammer
i don't know we'll convene a big thing
if people on clubhouse think it's cool
let's do it
i would thank you brian i would love to
talk with him i haven't contacted him
because i didn't want to waste his time
i'm reading his stuff
he taught a class at harvard in fall of
2019 i have
myself personally translated transcribed
17 of his lectures
i'm learning his stuff that's how
serious i'm about learning his stuff and
because i you know i'm really taken with
his work but i wanted to really
understand his work at a deeper level
before i wasted his time but i would
love to talk with him all right well
i'll get him on my show first and then
we'll get you both together so please
tune in on youtube dr brian keating
subscribe
uh to the into the impossible podcast
wherever you get it don have a wonderful
weekend thank you so much for joining us
and going into the impossible
thank you brian my pleasure any
sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
hello i'm stuart walker producer of into
the impossible
if you enjoyed this episode with
professor brian keating please let us
know by subscribing commenting
sharing and most importantly reading and
leaving reviews
it really helps keep our universe
expanding
we appreciate hearing from you and read
every review and comment
we're always open to your suggestions
for future episodes
watch our youtube channel at dr brian
keating d-r
brian keating and join our premieres
every tuesday at 8 am pacific time for
live chats
follow brian on twitter medium and
support us on patreon
at dr brian keating that's dr brian
keating
for free access to exclusive content
please visit professor keating's website
and sign up for his informative
newsletter at briankeating.com
into the impossible is produced with the
arthur c
clarke center for human imagination in
the division of physical sciences at the
university of california san diego
eric very director brian keating
co-director
pastor coleman associate director
produced by
stuart valko and brian keating for more
information
on the arthur c clarke center go to
imagination.ucsd.edu